seconds on the shot clock 11 on the
timer 19 seconds left in regulation
young had nowhere to throw it Boy Throw
it right into the groin
can we send it on TV was in his in his
intention it was an intention to not use
the timeout yes so smart it just caught
Mark Marcus you know a little below the
clock
looks like smart is okay
and again he throws it off Smart
I mean because he can't see over that
they're going to change you inbounds the
ball it's hard to portray young even if
somebody's open over the top because
it's shorter
now they're probably trying to get the
ball back to him once the ball got
inbounded but but smart play but not
using the timeout
Schneider still has it in his back
pocket
but they've got to work quickly here 10
seconds to shoot
DeAndre Hunter will be the inbounder
he works deep in their corner
throws it off of pork repeat that's
three straight times
[Applause]
Atlanta can't inbound but you don't have
a lot of room to work with on the
sideline from that Carlton Corner that's
why
Hunter fires they're going to turn it
over
I'll tell you it's it's